ANJALI WHEELER: Hi, everyone.
My name is Anjali Wheeler and
I'm the tech leader of 360
and 3D videos at YouTube.
So I'm going to talk
about three things today.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So I'm going to talk
about three things today.
I'm going to talk
about to 360 video.
about 3D video.
And then we mix
the two together,
and we talk about
360 and 3D together.
So by a show of hands, how many
of you have seen a 360 video?
How many of you have
seen a spherical video?
AUDIENCE: What's the difference?
ANJALI WHEELER:
They're the same thing.
[LAUGHTER]
Thanks for asking.
OK, so they're called
spherical videos,
because you can imagine
a viewer sitting inside
in the middle of the sphere
and looking outwards,
and that worldview.
I would have liked to create
one, but it's too much work.
[LAUGHTER]
So what do spherical
videos looks like?
So they're essentially
a sphere which
is projected onto
a flat surface,
and we call this
method projection.
And this method has been used
for a long time by map makers,
because the Earth
is a sphere, and we
like maps on a flat surface.
So this is a projection which
we call equirectangular,
and as you can see,
it's essentially
like a sphere, just
unwrapped and flattened out.
There are several
other projections
that have been used,
like the world map.
That's another example of
equirectangular projection.
And let's see these.
There's the quincencial on the
left, and there's the Goode.
And just as an
example, we want to use
things which are rectangular.
And the one on the right
that is not rectangular,
it's not useful for us, because
there are lots of wasted pixels
there.
So we don't use those
kinds of projections.
So let's talk about
how we shoot 360 video.
Today, there are lots of
cameras in the market which
can shoot 360 videos.
I have one here to show.
That's a Ricoh Theta.
It has two lenses on both sides.
They both take a 180
degree view of the world.
And once it shoots, they are
like all of these cameras,
have multiple lenses.
And the video
streams are several,
depending on the
number of lenses.
And after that, you use
a stitching software
to stitch them all together
into a single video frame.
So that's about capture.
Now once this video is ready,
you can upload it to YouTube.
So how does YouTube
know whether it's a 360
video or a standard video?
We tried several things there.
We tried auto-detection
to see-- we
had a filter that
will automatically
find out if a video is 360.
And the problem was, the
auto-detector was very good,
but it was not perfect.
And when you go
to YouTube scale,
even a 0.1% error is very big.
Imagine you uploading a 360,
and it's appearing weird,
and people who are
uploading standard video,
and that doesn't show up right.
So that wasn't enough for us.
Than we thought, OK,
let's do a check box.
When people upload
a video, they'll
tick a check box-- my
video is spherical.
It shows up very well.
It doesn't work.
And we tried it before
with the 3D videos.
So people uploaded 3D videos,
and there was a check box,
and the problem
was, a lot of people
didn't know how to
use it correctly
There were people whose videos
were not 3D that checked it,
and people with videos who
want 3D and it didn't check it.
And everyone was
frustrated, including us.
And so that didn't work well.
So we thought, OK,
the best way is
to have the 360 cameras include
some metadata in the video
to tell YouTube that
this video is 360.
And we approached the 360
camera makers with this idea.
We created a spec
for the metadata that
can be introduced into the
file, and the camera makers
like this idea.
They agreed to put
it in the file.
So this works.
And for a few cameras which
don't have the metadata,
we have a Python script that
you can run on your video.
It's not great.
I'm sorry.
But I hope that in future,
with time, all cameras
are going to put the
metadata in the file.
So with that, let's
talk about render.
So how do we render 360 videos?
We need some sort of a 3D
API, OpenGL, or DirectX
and we map the
decture of the video
onto these sphere mesh, just
the way it's supposed to be,
as per the projection.
And it works.
We have gravity
and gyro sensors,
so when you move your
device, the view pans.
Has everyone used it
on a mobile device?
How many of you have used
it on a mobile device?
OK, cool.
And so we call this mode
the magic window mode.
And that's because this device
is like a magical window
into another world, and you
can move this window around,
and it moves you
into the other world.
And the other is, of
course, the VR mode.
So that's cool.
I sort of have some sort of
a personal affinity to VR.
In the '80s, they were the
first set of VR headsets
that showed up.
And they weren't really great.
They were three 20
by 200 resolution.
They had five frames per
second, and they were heavy.
And nobody liked it,
and so I was bummed out.
Then in 1999, "The
Matrix" showed up,
and I was again revved up.
Yay, VR!
But, again, the world
was not ready for VR.
So I did the neatest
thing I could do.
I joined 3D FPS gaming job.
Anyways, so I'm happy that, now,
we are in a much better place
far VR, and the chances of
this succeeding this time
around a pretty high.
So with that, let's
talk about the quality
of spherical videos.
So in this projection that
we've been talking about,
there's a horizontal
field of view of 360,
and a vertical of 180.
This gives us six
pixels per degree.
So who knows what is the
I-resolution in terms
of pixels per degree?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANJALI WHEELER: Pardon me?
ANJALI WHEELER: Yeah.
So it's a 60 pixels per
degree, of [INAUDIBLE] minute.
So we are at 6, we
want to go to 60.
How do we go from 6 to 60?
And we are researching several
things to go from 6 to 60.
So it's the eye's
retina resolution.
And one of the
ideas is cropping.
Let's crop the top
and the bottom,
because people
don't look up when
they are watching
the 360 videos,
or they don't spend time
looking at the floor.
They look forward.
So how about we crop
them out, and then we
get close to ten
pixels per degree.
The other ideas are tiling.
Let's have several streams, and
when people turn their heads,
you switch to a new stream.
And dialing gives us another
advantage in horizontal.
We get almost 10.6.
We you combine them together.
We get 10 on both
sides, approximately.
And 4K [INAUDIBLE] are
just around the corner.
They're right there.
And so that takes us to 20.
So that's good.
We are close.
So that's one of the
things we're trying
to do-- improve the quality.
And another thing that is
tough with the spherical videos
is just the sheer
amount of data.
So if you look at this
image, the area under the red
is the area captured
by a standard video.
And we have like four
times more things there.
And add depth and 3D to
it, it gets even worse.
So that's another area
we'd like to improve upon.
So that's about 360, and
I'm going to talk about 3D
after this.
So are there any
questions so far?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANJALI WHEELER: Yeah.
But those features, we are
doing on a, you could say,
platform-by-platform basis.
So on the web, we support
zooming in and out.
And on other clients,
we do wish to.
And I cannot say
when we'd do it.
So let's talk about 3D.
It's sort of an old
story, but I feel
like I should talk about
it before we talk about 3D
and spherical together.
And so how do
humans perceive 3D?
This is a perfectly 2D image.
And I'm pretty sure
everyone of you
here can figure out what's
far away and what's close by.
So human can completely make
sense out of a completely 2D.
You could see a picture and
know what's far, what's near,
but we know that this is fake.
This is not real depth.
And so we perceive 3D by
something by disparity.
We have two eyes at two
different locations that see
two different use the world.
And we compute the difference,
and we figure out what's far
and what's near.
So that's what we
try to replicate
when we do 3D in computing.
And
one example is, there
are 3D cameras, which
just have two lenses set exactly
the same distance as human eye.
And they capture two
views, and we can just
put them side by side.
We can put them top and bottom.
And people have tried
every possible way
to do it-- interlaced and
temporal alternate frames-- one
for the left eye, one
for the right eye.
And all of them
produce, more or less,
similar results where there's a
viewing instrument that people
wear to filter the left and
the right eye correctly.
So we can always
watch a 2D view of 3D
through one of the eyes'
view and just watch it in 2D.
This is the anaglyph, or
these red and blue filters.
And we could polarized, which
most movie theaters do that,
and a lot of TVs have
organized glasses support too.
One downside with
polarization is
that it cuts the
brightness in half,
so the TV or the movie theater
has to be twice as bright.
Then we have VR.
Cool.
So that's about 3D.
So before I talk about
spherical, any questions on 3D?
No.
Cool.
So now we're going to
mix the two together.
We talked about top-bottom.
We talked about equirectangular.
And we mix the two
together, and we
get equirectangular top-bottom.
And that's the most
popular way today
to represent spherical videos.
How do we capture them?
JUMP.
There's a talk right after me.
You'll learn about JUMP there.
So let's talk about playback.
Playback is, again,
two of the same idea.
There's a magic window mode,
and there's a cardboard view.
And that's how people will be
able to enjoy spherical 3D.
We don't support it yet,
but we do plan to soon.
And so that's rendering part.
But when we introduce
3D, there are
a lot of things that
are needed to make
the users comfortable--
like, some people
get motion sick
when they watch VR,
and some people get headaches.
And so there are
some things to keep
in mind, for example, the IPD,
or the interpupillary distance.
So humans come in all shapes and
sizes, and so people whose eyes
are closer together, they
are not very comfortable
when they see VR, which is
made from the point of view
of somebody whose eyes
are farther apart.
So it's, essentially,
the head size.
And so we need to make
sure that the IPD is
right for the person,
and maybe provide a way
to calibrate and adjust for it.
They are field of view issues.
So there's been
research done on it,
and it was found that people
are more comfortable when
the field of view is hire.
People also get motion sick
more when the field of view
is higher.
So there's no good,
great path there.
It's a balance act.
And the third thing
is latency-- like when
people move their
head, how long does it
take for the image to move?
And that's, again,
something that
needs to be as low as possible.
So there's the tech aspects of
360, 3D, and the YouTube part.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]